you might get my best bro my family
anything anyway so
so yeah but these two guys just you can
see pretty awesome awesome awesome we
brought like one other person I brought
awesome eggs on the one woman
knock into microphones I'm afraid you
got a such pleasure
I'm not going to take a picture of this
year
sir
a Saturday morning please welcome for
the Wachowskis here with a big sci-fi
film Jupiter ascending Jail
it was gigawatt they were saying chick
why because we good so Kunis Sean Bean I
see are all some of the film tell us
about what is it like to work on the
movie what people can expect well you
never know what you're gonna get with
them they're they're absolutely out of
their minds I mean we really tried to do
something different something that
you've never seen before it's not you
know it's obviously not a book or a
comic or anything so they've really
really charged bushes yeah and obviously
couldn't be here as well so they say
sorry I think people are fine with the
fact that you're here you're nice 7,000
people screaming understanding that
a few change in them it's authorized
you're gonna be fine
well now sit over here alright awesome
did you do I did you bring any footage
you want to show people something